Speaker 1: Let's go to Miguel from central
Florida.
Miguel from central Florida, welcome to The
David Pakman Show.
What can I do for you today?
Speaker 3: Hi, David.
How does my mike sound?
Speaker 1: It sounds beautiful.
Speaker 3: Oh, perfect.
I wanted to ask, being someone that's coming
from Central Florida.
I've obviously seen kind of the the rise of
the Santas and a lot of the rise of the right
wing culture where issues.
Yep.
So I was wondering.
Considering DeSantis expanded his lead in.
Florida this time around.
To what extent would you place the blame on
the local Florida Democratic Party?
Or you can even translate it to the national
issue as well.
How much would you kind of assign the blame
to the Democratic Party for not being able
to effectively counter the kind of right wing
messaging that has dominated the media almost
since Trump has won the election?
Speaker 1: There's a couple of different things
here.
Part of this is timing.
And what I mean by that is I think that if
the DeSantis reelection in Florida were November
2023 rather than November 2022, I don't think
the Santos wins by 19 now, he probably still
wins.
But the reason I say he doesn't win by 19
is since November, the tide really has turned
on a lot of this culture war stuff that DeSantis
ran his campaign on.
So I think part of part of it was timing.
And timing was the reason DeSantis expanded
his his margin of victory.
Now, can we blame Democrats to some degree?
Sure.
You almost always can write like you can almost
always do something to lose by less, even
if you're going to lose than if you do nothing
at all.
I don't know enough about the internal dynamics
of the Florida, what's going on in Florida
to be able to specifically lay blame.
But I think big picture, big picture there
was like a peak in the culture war stuff right
around November 2022, which did help some
Republicans like the Santos.
And had those elections been held six months
later, like now, I think the results would
have been at least slightly different.
Speaker 3: Yeah, like I could actually see.
Unfortunately, I'd say that the the ground
game for the Florida Democratic Party is,
I'd say, almost nonexistent here.
Is that right?
See how though, it was I mean, back during
the election, I would have people knocking
on my door handing out the Santas pamphlets.
And I live in a blue county, you know, and
I didn't get a single Democratic person knock
on my door.
Although I will say that it was mostly the
unions that were out here trying to campaign
for candidates.
Interesting.
But I guess that would be a conversation for
another day, if anything.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Thank you for taking my call.
Thank you so much.
There is Miguel from Central Florida.
We're going to take the quickest of breaks
and then we're going to come right back here
and hear from more of you.
Okay.
So if you're holding on to talk to me, just
hold on a little bit longer.